we're on problem 135
i just did some pilates so i'm slightly
out of breath
if x is less than zero is y greater than
zero so if
x is less than zero
is y
y
greater than zero
all right statement number one
x
over y
is less than zero
x over y is less than zero
so this is actually pretty useful right
they're telling us that x is a negative
number
right so we have a negative here
and we're dividing it by some other
number and they're telling us that that
num that the resulting number is still
negative so we have a negative
divided by something
is equal to a negative
so i think you learned when you learned
negative numbers if if y was negative
well if y was 0 this would be undefined
and if y is negative if this was a
negative then the resulting
when you divide a negative by negative
you would have a positive so y has to be
a positive number and it can't be zero
so this actually tells us statement one
alone tells us that y is greater than
zero
just based on the fact that you have a
negative that is just telling you that a
negative divided by y is still negative
right this whole thing is still negative
so y has to be a positive
statement number two tells us
y
minus x
is greater than zero and that just tells
us that y let's see add x to both sides
it tells us that y is greater than x
well that's not enough it says if x is 0
is y greater than 0. x could be you know
maybe x is equal to
minus
10 and y is equal to minus 9. so in this
case y wouldn't be greater than zero or
maybe x is equal to minus 10 and y is
equal to plus 9.
both of these would satisfy this
condition so we don't know we this
doesn't tell us any information on
whether y is greater than or zero
greater than zero so statement one alone
is sufficient and statement two doesn't
do much for us
problem
no i already did 135 136
136 okay they've drawn a circle there so
i guess i'll draw a circle as well
so that's the circle
and they have see they have a center
the center
goes up like that
and then
looks like that and there's a right
angle right here
they call this o they call this x
they call this
z
and then they actually connect those two
points
they connect those two points
and then they call this
this point right here that's y
let's see what they're asking what is
the circumference of the circle above
with center oh so you just want another
circumference so if we could figure out
a radius then we know circumference is
two pi times the radius and we'd be all
set so let's see what they what
information they give us
statement number one
the perimeter of triangle o
x
z
is twenty
plus ten square roots of two
perimeter is equal to twenty
plus 10
square roots of 2.
this is interesting what do we know
about this
well we know this is going to be an
isosceles triangle we know that if if
this length right here is x
that this length is also going to be x
because this is a circle so a circle is
the radius is constant right and each of
these sides are the radius of the circle
so those are both going to be x and then
what is
what is this going to be it's going to
be hypot we just know from pythagorean
theorem x squared plus x squared
is going to be equal to that side
squared is going to be let's call that c
squared
so you get 2x squared is equal to c
or c
and i'm calling this side right here c
is equal to the square root of two x
times the square root of two
whatever x is right so the parameter the
sorry the perimeter of this entire
triangle is going to be two x's right x
plus x
so it's going to be 2x
plus
x square roots of 2
x square roots of 2.
and statement 1 told us that this
perimeter is equal to this right here is
going to be equal to 20 plus 10 square
roots of 2.
well i think you could do a little
pattern matching here and solve for x i
mean we have a this is actually even
though it might not look completely like
it this is a linear equation and you can
solve for it and and immediately that
should be oh statement one is sufficient
but you can just do a little pattern
matching and say well this works when x
is equal to 10.
so actually we are able to figure out
what x is equal to and then as i said
before x is the radius of the circle and
then the circumference of the circle
which is the whole question is about
that's 2 pi times the radius
circumference is 2 pi times the radius
we just figure out the radius is 10
so it equals 20 pi so statement 1 is
sufficient
what does statement 2 do
statement 2 the length of arc x y z is 5
pi
x y z is 5 pi so they're telling us that
this length is 5 pi
that that is 5 pi
well do we know what proportion that is
of the entire circumference well sure
because they tell us that this is
90 degrees right here right this is 90
degrees of 360 degrees of a circle so
this
the arc length
right here is exactly going to be
one-fourth of the circle and we know
that because 90 degrees is one-fourth
360.
so 5 pi is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to 1 4 times the
circumference or that the circumference
is going to be equal to 20 pi
so each statement independently
statement 1 or statement 2 independently
is sufficient to answer this question
the circumference of the circle
what is the value of a to the fourth
minus b to the fourth a to the fourth
minus
b to the fourth
and immediately just even looking i mean
one thing i'm tempted to do is rewrite
this as
a squared
squared
minus b
squared squared because i just glanced
at statement one they had squares there
so i'm going to do that
right and you know that a square let me
do different letters you know that x
squared minus y squared is equal to x
plus y
times x minus y right
so here x is a squared and y is b
squared so this is going to be equal to
this is just the original a to the this
is going to be equal to a to the squared
a squared plus b squared
times
a squared minus b squared
and then we could simplify this again so
this is going to be equal to a squared
plus b squared we could simplify this as
a plus b
times a
minus b
i think that's going to be helpful just
glancing at the two statements that they
gave us so statement one
tells us that a squared
a squared
minus b
squared a squared minus b squared is
equal to
is equal to 16.
so that tells us that just this is equal
to 16
that is equal to
16. that doesn't help me much because i
don't know what a squared plus b squared
is going to be it just tells me the
difference between these two squares it
doesn't tell me any i don't know what
they're integers or anything
statement two tells me that a
plus b
is equal to eight
and once again
that doesn't help me tremendously by
itself
right if i just know that a plus b is
equal to eight now i don't know what a
minus b is i don't know what all this is
but when i use them together this is
interesting right
because we know that a plus b
a plus b
times
a
minus b
is equal to a squared minus b squared
well they just told us that a plus b is
equal to eight so a plus b is equal to
eight
so eight times a
minus b
is going to be equal to a squared minus
b squared where statement 1 told us was
16.
so that actually tells us that a
minus b is equal to 2.
so now we have two equations with two
unknowns and we could solve for a and b
and if we can solve for a and b then we
can definitely tell you what a to the
fourth minus b to the fourth is and just
to show you that let me do it so let's
see a minus b is equal to 2 add these
equations 2a is equal to 10
a is equal to 5
and then if a is equal to five b is
equal to three
so
our original statement a to the fourth
is five to the fourth
five to the fourth
minus
three to the fourth
so whatever that's what 625 minus 81 i
think it doesn't matter you can figure
it out so both statements combined are
sufficient to answer this question see
you in the next video